[MUSIC PLAYING]
All righty!
So now that we know how to
submit scores to leader boards,
let's go through the process
of removing these hard coded
strings.
I'm going to do something
a little different
than the Achievement
Manager You'll
remember in the
Achievement Manager
we created a new enum for
each of the achievements.
Now I could do the same
thing for our leader boards,
but the thing is we
basically already
have an enum set up for this.
If you look in our
enums.h file, we
have this difficulty level one.
And since our leader
boards correspond exactly
to difficulty levels,
I'm just going
to go ahead and reuse this.
So let's see, I'm going
to set this to zero just
to kind of ensure
that, yes, easy really
is going to correspond to zero.
And then in our
leader board manager,
I'm going to create
a new method called
Submit Score for
Difficulty Level.
And let's write negative up
here and import my enums.
Difficulty level -- Next
code why are you giving me?
There we go.
Right.
Now to implement
this, I do still
need to create the
array of static strings
that lets me know what
leader board corresponds
to each difficulty level.
So I'm going to do our
static in a string const
leader board IDs.
And that will
equal-- And now I got
to go to my developer
console and make
sure I copy and paste these.
So let's bring that up.
There you go.
And copy this one.
Let's copy this one.
I think these are really all the
same except for the last letter
here, but just in case I always
like copying and pasting.
Here we go.
And we can do this.
And we can create a little in a
string for our leader board ID.
And that equals our
leader board ID's level.
And you know what?
I'm just going to combine
these two methods into one.
So there we go.
We get our leader
board ID by looking
at our leader board ID's array.
And then basically
I'm just going
to combine this with the
rest of the sinit square
for leaderboard ID method.
Now I basically just need to go
back to my .h file and delete
this method because we
no longer want to use it.
And we're pretty good.
So now I can go back
to my game model class
and replace this
method, where I'm
submitting a score to a hard
coded leader board string,
to just leader board,
managers, submit score,
num_guesses for
difficulty level.
And oh, at this point I
realized you know what,
I'm not actually storing the
difficulty level anywhere
in this class.
Well this is
something we can fix
with a simple property
or a variable.
Let me just go up here
and add it as a property.
By the way, I often
go back and forth
about whether I should be
storing these private variables
as you know, little ints
here, or has actual properties
in the class extension.
I go back and forth.
I'm not quite sure
if one way's really
considered more
proper than the other.
But I'm just going to
go ahead and do it here.
Going to create
a little int that
is going to store
our difficulty level.
So there we go.
I do know however that since
I've kind of created most
of these others as properties,
I don't know why I'm referring
to them using their private
variable names with this
_gamemax _secretnumber.
I should probably be using
some self dot notation here.
Sorry about that.
But in any case I guess I'll
be consistently incorrect here
and we'll store our
difficulty level
as the level that
gets passed in.
And now that this
has been recorded
I can now go back to the bottom
here and for difficulty level
I can now change that to
difficult level property.
And there you go.
Let's run this now.
And we'll see that well hey
look at that, three guesses.
I got a better
score than before.
And by the way, you will
notice as I mentioned
before in this score
report that gets returned,
the high score for player today
all those Booleans are true
and the actual high
score objects are null.
Remember those only get
returned if you did not
get a new high score for today
or for the week or all time.
And now what's even better
is without any extra work
on my part, I can now go ahead
and play a medium difficulty
game.
Boy, I guess I should have
made a more fun game to play.
There we go.
And now I've
submitted a high score
to the medium leader
board as well.
Let's go back, check
our leader boards.
Here's our medium
leader board and there I
am with a score of 10.
I could likewise do the same
for the hard difficulty level
but I really don't want
to play a game where
I guess a number
between 1 and 10,000.
So I will leave that as
an exercise to the viewer.
So we're almost done here.
The only other
refinement I want to make
is I found it sort of awkward
they had to go back here
to this mean screen
to view the leader
boards for the game
I was just playing.
Gee, wouldn't it be
nice if in the middle
of playing my easy game I could
see the current high scores.
And so we can do that
pretty easily as well.
And we'll tackle that final
step in the next lesson.
So I'll see you soon.